all right and finally allow me to
introduce this year's gold medal award
winner near to filmmaking it's brian
schwartz with this film old daddy Brian
wow wow um thank you thank you everyone
for being here um I really have no idea
what I'm doing up here at this moment
but I couldn't be more happier I would
like to thank the academy for for
multiple reasons but first for for
liking my film enough to just be first
invited to be invited to this week it's
been it's been wonderful everyone's been
so generous so gracious so friendly so
open I've learned may of just that I
have that it's such great advice from
everyone I've spoken to and it's it
really was a true pleasure it exceeded
my expectations you know tenfold so
thank you so much for that I'd also I'd
like to thank or i'd also like to take a
big congratulations to all the other
filmmakers watching your films the other
day was was incredible and I times was
wondering what mine was doing hey in
such in such a in such good company so
you guys are all very incredibly
talented and I'm excited to see what you
all do beyond this I'd like to say
thanks to the RTF department at the
University of Texas at Austin that's the
radio television film program they have
a great faculty you know a an
enthusiastic student body that that's
very supportive of Austin itself is an
incredible film community who's very
supportive so a couple faculty members
that they were really instrumental and
helping me get this far Stewart Calvin
who was a screenwriter who really helped
me hone the scripts and I in which I
sort of attribute a lot of the success
of the movie the ax to to the script
that and he was
a really big part of that so Andrew Shay
was a big help and to the the entire
faculty who helped me from from year one
to year five but but that's okay um to
the cast and crew the wonderful cast and
crew we did this on a very low budget it
was just it was all sort of passion guts
sweat and tears and which which got it
made and you know all it was almost all
student actors with the exception of a
few almost completely students crew who
just gave their time but it was just
like a half a day and then or a couple
days here and there we we strung it
together it wasn't the easiest shoot but
but everyone was so committed I liked I
guess it's a shoutout to John Cook and
Roberts talero who the father and son
who did a tremendous job to the crew
Marcel Rodriguez is a great
cinematographer in Austin and he did a
terrific job to Vic who was the
production designer and I mean I'm going
to forget people Alex Thomas and my two
wonderful producers who who helped me
from from day one Ashley and Leslie
Saunders who are just been supportive
and fearless and I can't thank you guys
enough to actually for being a wonderful
and loving and supportive girlfriend
throughout all of this I really really
want to say thank you for that and to my
family my mom my dad and my sister and
my cat moo at home I would just I want
to say thank you so much for for just
sort of for being a real source of
support if I this was the real ass
because I know the music would have
started a long time ago so thank you so
much everyone this is a huge honor thank
you thank you so much
you